okay
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today we'll be doing another harper's
bazaar food diaries video and taking a
look at everything that former got7
member and current higher music solo
artist jb eats in a day but first let me
tell you about my sponsor bespoke post
so the past two years have been quite
emotionally challenging for a lot of us
but one thing i definitely look forward
to each month to keep my spirits high
are my monthly bespoke post boxes
so bespoke post is a monthly membership
club delivering top shelf goods from
under the radar brands they purchase 90
of their products in the boxes from
small businesses and they curate them
into really cool themed boxes that you
get to experience based on your
preferences
so this month i got the weekender which
is going to be so key for any little
weekend college getaways or i don't know
shipping the kids off to grandma's
and i also got the salud which is going
to be perfect for said cottage weekend
or childless night now this one includes
some beautiful hand blown glasses a hand
juicer margarita mix chili salt and a
fun dish towel so hurray for spicy
margarita night now the way it works is
that you fill out your preference quiz
and each month you get matched to a box
based on what you like but the best
thing is that you get to see it before
it ships so you can decide if you want
to keep it swap it for another box or
skip the month for no charge and if you
do decide to keep it it's really great
deal since the boxes retail for around
70 dollars but only cost 45 each so if
you want to try this out today for
yourself or as a gift for that really
hard to buy for a friend you can get 20
off of your first box by clicking the
link in the description and using my
code abbeysharp20 at checkout or just go
to bsp
dot me slash abby sharp 20. now before
we get into it feel free to pause the
screen or look at the description to
check out my disclaimer including a
trigger warning for those with current
or previous experiences with disordered
eating as always feel free to skip this
video if it's not supportive to your
journey and if you are new here hello
welcome um definitely be sure to
subscribe to this channel and ring that
little bell so that you never miss out
on an episode
alrighty folks let's dive in
first off the sweet potato staple is
giving me a bit of kpop diet ptsd
and if you watch my video right here
you'll know exactly what i mean
i have nothing against sweet potatoes i
love sweet potatoes and i love them for
breakfast because they're rich in
antioxidants and fiber
but there is a massive obsession in kind
of the k-pop diet culture with the whole
sweet potato diet which is a great
great example of the phrase too much of
a good thing thankfully i'm not just
seeing a sweet potato monomial here you
know we've got a little more variety
so jb's breakfast is certainly way more
adequate than like the typical k-pop
diet that i've reviewed i mean we've got
some protein here from the chicken as
well as some extra carbs and fiber from
the apple and sweet potato
it's definitely a very simple meal and i
would love to see maybe some healthy
fats in there so perhaps like a sauce
for the chicken or some nut butter with
the apples but i also know that the
typical kpop diet is quite low in fat
so we definitely just need to see how
the rest of the day unfolds
basically
so plum tea is actually a very popular
korean drink and it sounds super
delicious and like coffee i don't care
what your morning beverage ritual is as
long as it's not served with a side of
pseudoscience
but i will say that one in vitro study
did find that tea made from plum extract
may help to stimulate muscle protein
synthesis and inhibit protein
degradation and i will also say that
plums do contain a variety of organic
acids and antioxidants so yes there is
some nutrition to be had here
but i'll also note that this is research
done in a petri dish not actual humans
in real life so i wouldn't expect
anything magical to come from drinking a
cup of the stuff and while i've seen a
lot of online influencers extrapolating
some of these alleged health claims
i didn't actually see any bs from jb
himself so i'm happy to say nothing to
report here
trouble bankers
[Music]
i feel like oolong's pr team needs to
step it up a bit because green tea seems
to get like all the wellness woo fanfare
but it actually ranks quite similarly to
green and black tea in terms of its
antioxidant potential and it contains
roughly the same amount of caffeine as
green tea there's also a fair bit of
cohort based research suggesting that
habitually drinking oolong tea
may provide brain bone and heart health
benefits so if you like something that
is more or less kind of like a hybrid
between green and black tea
then oolong might be a really great
choice
from
and i tried to look up how to pronounce
that so i do apologize that it's not
perfect is a popular korean barbecue
dish that's basically marinated
pork in all the really good stuff like
soy sauce sesame oil garlic ginger and
one of my all-time favorite korean
ingredients gochujang
i am
obsessed and while i think a lot of my
north american followers watching may
think well where's the avocado toast or
protein pancakes for breakfast lemon
water i think it's a really good
reminder that most cultures don't
pigeonhole certain flavors or certain
foods into certain meals of the day
and there's actually no physiological
benefit to it either so for those of you
stuck in like a breakfast rut
maybe re-evaluate what foods you deem
appropriate for the morning this to me
looks like a super satisfying second
breakfast so we've got lots of protein
and some fat in the marinated pork and i
love that he's kind of revitalized
leftovers with his own little unique
spin
but i would love to see this paired with
some rice or maybe that morning sweet
potato for some energizing carbs and it
also would be very easy to like throw in
some leftover veggies as well while he's
refrying
[Music]
okay
listen we are all super busy and i also
know that the schedule of these kpop
artists is borderline inhumane so i know
that fitting in meals can often feel
like a task but given the energy demands
of rehearsals and performing
you gotta make eating a priority
and this applies even if you're just
sitting at your desk like i do all day
long think about it
if you have time to put makeup on or do
your hair or even work out or watch this
video right now
you have time to sit down to a meal and
while it's a bit hard to follow
i think what jb is saying here is that
taking the time to eat helps to ensure
that he eats the right amount and
doesn't overeat in like a desperate
state of
so this is why i always talk about the
gas gauge if we let ourselves get right
down on empty we tend to make kind of
frantic hasty decisions and it's hard
not to overeat but eating when we've
reached a moderate level of hunger
allows us to be more mindful with our
meals and land ourselves at a more
comfortable state of fullness
so if this video doesn't motivate you to
order some korean food tonight
i don't know what will so jb's go to's
for lunch are kimchi jjigae which is
like a kimchi stew as well as don jiang
jigae which is a stew made from soybean
paste and one thing that i love about
korean food is that not only is it super
super flavorful but it also incorporates
a lot of really nutritious fermented
foods like kimchi and soybean paste this
not only gives each dish a unique cake
of flavor but also offers some really
great gut healthy probiotics as well
there's also some research suggesting
that fermented foods actually help to
make nutrients from food more easily
absorbed by the body which to me is
really a win-win all around
now i didn't hear him state this but
usually korean food is served with ban
con i hope i'm pronouncing that right
but these are like little side dishes
like cooked rice and other veggies so
i'm assuming we're getting some
vegetables in there along with the carbs
from some rice
which typically complement the protein
in the stews and i also have to
acknowledge the guy does seem to use
some oil when he's kind of stir-frying
his meals because i just feel really
relieved that we're not dealing with the
typical k-pop fat-free oil phobia that i
commented on right here
number one
all right so
even though jb suggests he's not much of
a snacker
it's great that when he does decide that
he feels like a snack
he actually seems to talk about a lot of
these kind of like sweet foods like
chocolate and stuff like that
very joyously also i just want to say
that i know society has equated snacks
with like ultra processed or less
nutritious foods
but i really would like us to reclaim
that term to just basically mean like a
mini meal
yes snacks absolutely can include fun
foods but their purpose is really to
kind of carry you from one meal to the
next and that to me means focusing on
the hunger crushing combo
so if you want milk chocolate pair that
chocolate with some nuts or some yogurt
or maybe like throw it into my protein
oats for example like i did in my hunger
crushing combo video right here
okay so i'm definitely seeing a
preference towards takeout meals here
which i think is kind of how a lot of
our generation nowadays eats given our
busy lifestyles but restaurant and
takeout food is typically quite high in
sodium and saturated fat and a lot of
korean takeoff dishes do depend on like
high sodium broths lots of soy sauce and
soy based paste
also like north americans adults in
korea are on average consuming
significantly more sodium than what
health authorities do recommend so in
2012 south korea implemented a national
plan to reduce sodium intake to try to
get intake to 3 500 milligrams per day
by 2020 which is still about 170 more
than the recommended amount
now whether or not a low sodium diet is
actually that important for overall
health is currently up for debate
we know however that excess sodium can
increase the risk of stomach cancer and
high blood pressure but a large cochrane
review meta-analysis found that a low
salt diet didn't actually have a
significant impact on heart disease risk
or death
in other words it seems to benefit the
blood pressure numbers but not
necessarily the risk of dying from high
blood pressure
confusing i know what the hell are you
talking about
but that's why we can't really look at
any one health marker in isolation now
heart health aside another side effect
of getting too much sodium is bloating
and since in this clip he actually did
say that eating two slices of pizza
makes him feel very very full
i would just want to be mindful that a
lot of sodium may also cause a similar
uncomfortable feeling so i know he's
super busy but i would try to encourage
cooking a few meals a week at home or if
that's just totally not realistic just
trying to ensure that he's enjoying a
variety of potassium rich veggie based
ban con to help balance the sodium
levels in the body
[Music]
okay so i just love how jb attributes
his enjoyment of seafood from his love
of the ocean and fishing
this is such a great reminder that food
is so much more than just nutrients and
calories in fact research has even found
that food memories both positive and
negative are significantly associated
with food choices and our general
attitude and behaviors towards food and
that is really not surprising
um
[Music]
so obviously choosing water most often
is ideal which it sounds like jb does
and while yes we do have correlational
research linking sugar sweetened
beverages consumption to things like
obesity and chronic disease
it's very important to note that this is
correlational research it's not like you
have one soda and you get diagnosed with
diabetes or heart disease so i truly
believe that if you love an occasional
coke or sprite and that's what brings
you joy then you can absolutely work
this into your week in the context of a
balanced nutrient-rich diet without any
significant impact on your health it
doesn't need to be all or nothing
good
okay so these all sound delicious and
especially in the case of the yogurt
even relatively nutritious when it comes
to dessert but he did mention needing to
eat the yogurt from his parents even if
he doesn't want to which is actually not
really an approach that i recommend
parents take research suggests that
using pressure or implementing like the
clean plate club
generally actually results in picky
eating or in enjoying food less not more
so if you want to learn more about
evidence-based feeding strategies or
picky eating strategies definitely check
out my video right here
okay first off i'm so effing hungry now
after that little montage um but i gotta
say we've made it this far without
hearing the big d word
but alas
here we are
now generally speaking i am appreciative
that the meals he cited here don't set
off my like kpop die culture alarm bells
aside from occasionally skipping lunch
which we talked about and the virtually
fat-free first breakfast meal
and i will say that i appreciate that
his discussion around foods
feels pretty joyful and unrestricted but
i would be shocked if he didn't feel
some pressure by the kpop diet culture
to look a certain way
and since he did mention enjoying late
night foods when he's not dieting i
really want to remind everyone that
eating at night
doesn't inherently make you gain weight
eating calories in excess
any time of day causes weight gain also
eating four fried chicken legs over two
days that's just two pieces of fried
chicken that's like 400 calories that's
not a massive mukbang cheat day and if
you pair that with maybe some veggies
and some rice
you've got a normal size meal not
something to freak out about likewise
with the sashimi that's actually a
really nutrient-dense choice
so if you have forbidden foods that
you've got rules about and you want to
start to think of them in more morally
neutral terms
definitely watch my video on building
trigger foods into balanced meals right
here i think that'll give you a lot of
great ideas and how you can work those
into your everyday now with all that
said what are my thoughts on jb's diet
well despite a little seemingly
inevitable kpop diet influence overall
it sounds like jb approaches food from a
place of enjoyment and sunlight also
convenience rather than a place of
restriction or reductionist wellness
culture beliefs he seems to really enjoy
foods from every food group and doesn't
explicitly demonize anything or make
unsubstantiated claims about ingredients
or food components like we saw with this
other kpop idol that i reviewed
i also just love that he seems to
embrace the joyful nostalgic and
emotional roles of food in addition to
its physical and nutrient based roles if
i had any gentle nutrition tips for jb
it would be to try to prioritize home
cooking a little bit more
this would just ensure that he's getting
some extra fiber love in there and
balancing those sodium-rich meals with a
little bit more potassium-rich
vegetables
but otherwise i think he's got a really
good sense of what feels good to his
body and how much he needs to eat to
help fuel his very busy life
and on that note that is all that i have
for you guys today if you like this
video be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below with who you'd
like to see review next subscribe to the
channel and i'll see you next time on
abby's kitchen bye
you